one silk handkerchief hmm a rich guy
won't watch obviously a criminal and one
mobile phone
oh yes that movie about a greedy
capitalist reminds me of that other one
this is why we're here because this
little gray rock sells for 20 million a
kilo you know where they attacked the
nobel movie or that flick where the
capitalist creates a killer virus
sacrifices people to aliens spreads
leukemia harvests organs again and again
chops down the last rainforest poisons
of town covers up inconvenient studies
corporate price-fixing nuclear
catastrophe even murder and they're so
ugly those capitalists I once said greed
is good it's deja vu all over again how
it seems it's legal legal rulers have
always exploited others so capitalism
didn't create greed but like a ref it
enforces rules no stealing no fraud no
violence to channel greed toward
productive things play by the rules and
greed gets you the iPad break the rules
and you get Bernie Madoff mix greed with
government and you get corporate
bailouts no Michael that ain't
capitalism true capitalism would have
let those companies sink like sock
puppet I lost everything
truth is capitalism gives us all kinds
of good stuff including Hollywood movies